let's go uh next
to
cody from san diego how is san diego i
was there not long ago love the weather
great restaurants
hey david can you hear me yes i can
uh it's pretty great down here in san
diego you know good pretty pretty good
weather um
i didn't uh i kind of had a just a
scenario i
wanted to comment on um it's kind of
like
just accepting uh just being a dumer and
accepting uh that republicans very well
may win in 2022 and yeah looking forward
to 2024
if likely scenarios keep on happening
and they win then as well um what's
what what do you think the climate looks
like i mean back in
2016
kind of the narrative around
that i was hearing
back then was
it whether trump or hillary wins it's
kind of like
not necessarily going to affect the
daily lives of the middle class
and
like we kind of see
some of the repercussions now do you
think it's going to be
like very
like incremental repercussions type of
thing or is it going to be
kind of drastic swing changes that we'll
see
uh take place
um
right away uh if a scenario like that
would happen just wanted to i don't know
that i understand you're saying if
republicans take the house and senate in
the midterms how radical will the change
be is that what you're saying
yeah yeah in the midterms and then also
if that compounds into them taking the
white house in 2024. 2024 is too far
away to say because it that that's a few
layers away
here's the things that will change very
quickly if republicans take the house
and senate in november
first of all
no bills are getting passed so you know
biden did infrastructure he did a
coveted stimulus bill you know there's a
number of different bills that were
passed
nothing is going to get done nothing it
just there will be nothing done for two
years except you know if there is the
most dire emergency where the congress
absolutely has to do something they're
going to do it but it will basically be
two years of obstructing joe biden in an
even more overt way than is being done
right now number two yes probably there
will be house investigations into joe
biden and hunter biden and they may even
impeach him and they will very quickly
make the united states a joke again
the way it was under um donald trump so
i think that
you know when we say well the middle
class won't really be directly affected
ah well i guess that remains to be seen
um but our
the reputation of the united states will
very quickly go into the toilet again as
a laughing stock so it remains to be
seen how quickly they will do these
things but they will do them and
unfortunately i do think they're going
to win in the fall
yeah yeah and that's the scenario i see
as well but yeah
just to kind of compound on on your
point do you think
what do you think the tangible um
i guess repercussions of a joe biden
impeachment would be
well i don't think it would remove him i
think it would just be remember the
impeachment is what the house does and
then the senate would either convict or
acquit i don't think that that he would
get convicted because he didn't do
anything wrong uh yeah and so that's
that's a factor even with republicans
having a slight majority in the senate i
don't think that joe biden gets
convicted on impeachment i think it will
just become a charade it will become a
distraction and it will just build the
humiliation of the united states
globally
yeah well i appreciate your comments
thanks all right cody from san diego
thank you keep enjoying the uh the good
weather there
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy dot com slash pacman the
link is right underneath this video